-Craven Trump supporters
like Senator Marco Rubio
are trying to downplay
the severity
of the federal
criminal investigation
into the classified materials
found at Trump's
Mar-a-Lago resort.
Meanwhile,
a Trump-appointed judge
granted what legal scholars
across the political spectrum,
including Trump's own
former attorney general,
considered an absurd request
to slow down
the Justice Department's
investigations.
So, you know...
that sucks.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, wait, I forgot.
We do a whole segment
about stuff like that.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
You know, we always joke
around the office here
about how the craziest
news stories
always seem to break
on Friday night
or when we have a week off
and how we wish we had a show
so we could talk about it.
We've been off for four weeks,
and you know what happened
the Monday of our
first week off?
The FBI search of Mar-a-Lago.
[ Laughter ]
I was on vacation with my family
and I said to my wife,
"The feds found classified
documents at Trump's residence,
but we don't have shows
for a month.
What am I supposed to do now?"
And then she said to me,
"I don't know, maybe be a father
to your three children?"
And then I said a bunch
of stuff back to her,
but under my breath
while I was walking away
so she couldn't hear it.
Point is...
[ Laughter ]
...it's so nice to be back.
And it wasn't just
Trump scandal stuff we missed.
Joe Biden and the Democrats
strung together a bunch
of surprise victories
both legislatively
and politically,
bumping Biden's poll numbers
in hopes that Democrats
can hold onto power
as midterm season ramps up.
And you can tell Biden's
got some pep in his step now.
I mean, before
when he was slogging
through the doldrums
of his presidency
with record-low
approval ratings,
just getting COVID
over and over again
like they were accidentally
treating his COVID
with more COVID...
And he would do that thing
where he'd close his eyes
and lower his head whenever
a reporter asked him a question
like he was in physical pain.
He looked like Chris Pine
at the Venice Film Festival.
That was the posture of a man
who spent eight years
as vice president and thought,
"How hard could this job be?"
then got the job and immediately
realized it only looked easy
because Obama was
the one doing it.
Obama made being president
look like a cross between
being a record producer
and an Instagram influencer.
"For more tutorials
on the debt ceiling, uhhh,
smash that follow button."
But that was the old Biden.
And look at him now.
He's a completely
different guy,
as you can tell from
some of his recent rallies
where, among other things,
he championed a bill
to cap prescription drug prices
for Medicare patients
and touted the power
of women voters.
-We beat pharma this year.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We beat pharma this year,
and it mattered.
We're gonna change
people's lives.
MAGA Republicans don't have
a clue about the power of women.
[ Crowd cheers ]
Let me tell you something.
They are about to find out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh. Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
-He's got...
[ Laughter ]
Got so much confidence now.
He's turned into Barry White.
[ Laughter ]
It's too bad those guys
never got to work together.
-♪ Can't get enough
of your love, babe ♪
-Oh. Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Anyway, Biden is clearly
laser-focused
on the growing list
of accomplishments
during his tenure
and a string of big victories
in special elections
that have revived Democrats'
political fortunes.
But he has one
very formidable obstacle
in his way -- Donald Trump,
a rival with unparalleled
political instincts.
A man with his finger
on the pulse of the electorate.
A candidate with the foresight
and discipline
to stay strictly on message
and make sure he's connecting
with voters
over the kitchen-table issues
they care about, like this.
-If you want to see
a dead bird cemetery,
go under a windmill sometime.
It's not a pretty sight.
-Okay, but...
[ Laughter ]
What if I don't want to see
a dead bird cemetery?
Is that an option?
Also, what do you mean,
"dead bird cemetery"?
[ Laughter ]
Is there such a thing
as an alive bird cemetery?
[As Trump]
I bury them up to their necks.
They never stop chirping.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] Trump's windmill
obsession has been going on
for like a decade now,
and it's somehow
getting creepier.
He used to complain about them
being ugly and noisy,
and now he's basically the kid
from "Stand By Me."
"You guys want to see
a dead bird cemetery?"
[ Laughter ]
I'd hate to get sight-seeing
advice from Trump.
What should we do
while we're in New York, Donald?
[As Trump] There's a lot of dead
geese by the airport.
You should check that out.
Remember,
Sully Sullenberger, he saved --
he saved that airplane,
but he killed a lot of geese.
Nobody remembers the dead geese.
But I do. I do.
I remember once
a goose came up to me --
big goose, strong goose --
tears in his eyes
and running down his bill --
Beak? I don't know.
And he said to me --
I'll never forget
what he said to me.
He said, "Sir...
Honk!"
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] But I guess...
I guess if I was Donald Trump
and I was also under
like 97 different
criminal investigations,
I, too, would be trying
to draw America's focus
to the nation's
dead bird cemeteries.
I mean, the CFO
of his family company
just pleaded guilty to tax fraud
and promised to cooperate
in the investigation
of the Trump Organization.
The state attorney general
is investigating
his company for fraud.
The Fulton County
district attorney
is investigating Trump's
threatening phone call
to the Georgia
secretary of state
to try to overturn
the state's election results.
There are at least two federal
grand juries that we know of,
investigating the January 6th
insurrection and a scheme
to submit counterfeit electors
to keep Trump in power.
And of course, now perhaps
the most serious them all,
a criminal investigation
into Trump
apparently just jacking a bunch
of closely guarded government
secrets from the White House
and keeping them in the closet
of his gold-plated swamp hotel
the way the rest of us hoard
old receipts from CVS.
And just as a quick refresher,
since the month of August
has been, in news terms,
about three centuries long,
the materials the FBI seized
weren't just innocuous
government documents.
They were reportedly
some of the most sensitive
documents the government has.
-The FBI found 184 classified
documents in 15 boxes.
That includes 25 documents
marked as top secret.
-According to the FBI,
some of the material was marked
with the highest levels
of classification that exists,
material that is meant
to be held
only in secure
government facilities,
not at a private club
where basically anyone can pay
for a membership
and wander around.
Arguably, the agents
most alarming finding
that we were able to see
in this redacted version
was that the boxes contained
classified information
that came from
human intelligence sources,
meaning that if the documents
were mishandled or leaked
or transmitted,
it could compromise the identity
of American intelligence assets.
-The government says it found
more than 40 folders
with "classified" markings
that were empty.
-So, Donald Trump gets to steal
highly classified material
containing some of the
government's most closely
guarded secrets
from the White House,
but if I do so much as borrow
a stamp from the supply closet,
I get a bill for 60 cents
from an all-caps email from H.R.
that says, "Reminder: Office
supplies are exclusive property
of NBC Universal
and cannot be used
for personal business."
So, let me see
if I'm following this.
The FBI found
national defense documents
that could potentially
compromise the identities
of American personnel --
documents with some
of the highest classification
markings that exist,
in the storage closet
of Donald Trump's
highly secured
fortified compound --
Oh, I'm sorry.
I read that wrong.
In the basement
of Donald Trump's Palm Beach
wedding venue for dentists
and their second wives,
where a bunch of spies
or tourists
or Trump's lumpy adult sons
could just wander around
and see them.
And on top of that, some of the
classified folders were empty.
Where did the documents
that were in those folders go?
Has Trump been giving them out
as party gifts to club members?
When you sit down at your table,
does the menu give you
a choice of chicken,
fish, or nuclear codes?
All this time,
I thought foreign spies
had to go to extreme lengths
to infiltrate highly secure
government buildings.
And in reality,
it turns out all they need to do
is sidle up to Trump
at the omelet bar.
[Russian accent]
Hello. My name is John Smith.
I would like Denver omelet.
[As Trump]
The Denver omelet is great,
but wouldn't you rather have
some troop locations?
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice]
Now, as a delay tactic,
Trump asked a judge to appoint
what's known as a special master
to sift through the documents
and separate out anything
that's privileged or personal.
And yesterday, a judge appointed
by Trump and handpicked
by the right-wing
Federalist Society
granted that request,
despite the fact
that legal experts
across the political spectrum
consider the request absurd.
Various legal experts
told The New York Times
yesterday that the decision
was "genuinely unprecedented,
deeply problematic,
and thin at best,"
with one even going so far
as to claim that "to any lawyer
with serious federal criminal
court experience
who is being honest,
this ruling is laughingly bad."
Well, sure, if you're gonna
limit it to lawyers with serious
federal criminal court
experience, we're being honest.
What about the lawyers
that don't fit that category?
Did the biased New York Times
interview any of them?
[As Giuliani] If you ask me,
this ruling makes perfect sense.
Almost as much sense
as marrying my cousin.
It's a wedding
and a family reunion.
Two birds with one windmill.
[Normal voice]
Even Trump's own
former attorney general,
Bill Barr, who you may recall
did everything in his power
to shield Trump from
the Mueller investigation,
thought the special master
request was nonsense.
-Well, I think the whole idea
of a special master
is a bit of a red herring.
The only documents
that have been taken,
it seems to me, that there's
a legitimate concern
about keeping away
from the government
and insulating the government
from would be documents
relating to his private
lawyer communications --
him as an individual
and his outside lawyers.
If there's stuff
like that, fine.
Identify it.
There doesn't appear
to be much of it.
I'm not sure you need
a special master to identify it.
Any other documents that were
seized, like news clippings
and other things that were
in the boxes containing
the classified information,
those were seizable
under the warrant
because they show the conditions
under which the classified
information was being held.
So, I think it's a red herring.
-Even Bill Barr is calling this
special master thing bull[bleep]
and he's the guy
who preemptively released
misleading snippets
of the Mueller report
to make it look like
the report exonerated Trump
when the reality
was the exact opposite.
And that's when you know
things are bad --
when your own henchmen
turn on you.
It would be like if Wally
started doing cue cards
for James Corden.
-Sorry, Seth.
He let me have my own segment
called "Card-Pool Wally-oke."
-Wally!
What was Paul like?
-Oh, Paul was super nice.
Very down to earth.
You'd like him.
Ehh, I'm not sure
he'd like you, but --
-Wally!
[ Laughter ]
But, you know, all else aside,
I have to say,
I'm actually quite impressed
by the courage
and bravery many Republicans
have shown in criticizing Trump
for this obviously
brazen criminal act.
They're finally showing
some spine.
Like Marco Rubio,
who had some pretty harsh words
for Trump's mishandling
of classified information.
-Even if it wasn't
marked classified,
I would know it's classified
because there are
other indicators
in those documents
that make it clear.
In fact, just by reading
the kind of information,
you know that it has to be
classified.
Sometimes it's not
just classified
because of the information,
but because embedded
in the information
is how it was acquired.
You don't want your adversaries
to know
how you acquire information.
-And the risk of that is...?
-The risk of that
is that we're giving opponents
of this government
or adversaries some insight
into our thinking,
into our decision-making,
and it provides them
most certainly an advantage
in the national security realm.
-Thank you, Senator Rubio.
A true profile in courage.
Say what you want about the man,
but at least
he's finally speaking up
and taking on Donald Trump's
obvious criminality
and abuses of power
and warning Americans
of the risk Trump posed to --
Wuzzat?
Oh, all those clips
were from 2015
and he was talking about
Hillary Clinton's emails?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, man.
What a silly
and unexpected mix-up.
This is what happens
when you take a month off.
You mess up and you play
a clip package
that inadvertently proves
how craven and hypocritical
Trump supporters are,
which was not my goal.
[ Laughter ]
I apologize to you, Senator.
Let's hear what
Rubio actually had to say
about Trump's stolen
classified materials.
I'm sure he was consistent.
-This is really, at its core,
a storage argument
that they're making, right?
They're arguing there
are documents there.
They don't deny that he should
have access to those documents.
What they deny is that
they were not properly stored.
I don't think a fight
over storage of documents
is worthy of what they've done.
-I'm sorry, you think
this is a storage issue?
The Justice Department
shouldn't have sent the FBI,
but rather Marie Kondo?
[ Laughter ]
[As Trump] I need your help
sparking joy, Marie.
I've got papers everywhere.
My mood is foul.
Plus, someone keeps
knocking over
the tombstones
in my dead bird cemetery.
Would -- Would you like to see
my dead bird cemetery?
What's that, Marie?
You don't need to say "dead"
when you say "cemetery"?
Why is that, Marie? Why?
Oh, because cemetery
implies the birds are dead.
Look at that -- you're already
tidying up my grammar, Marie.
I think we're gonna
get along just fine.
[Normal voice] When it comes
down to it, it's very simple.
It's a question of whether
or not everyone,
including Donald Trump,
is equal under the law.
Because if anyone else
was caught with those
documents in their possession,
they'd face consequences
immediately.
Mar-a-Lago is no place
for top secret documents.
The only place less secure
would be a...
-Dead bird cemetery.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.